so secretary of state anthony blinken
heading to costa rica today
to meet with central american foreign
ministers to discuss as you've heard
this is the goal of the bind
administration they want to find out how
to stem
the flow of migrants into the united
states kamala harris is supposed to be
in charge of this
yet lincoln has still not visited the
southern border to see what's going on
there in person
and neither has the vice president
despite being named the point person
as we keep count there 69 days ago that
was meanwhile the body administration
reportedly looking to
up the number of immigrants in america
the new york times the new york po
times pardon me saying quote a 46-page
draft blueprint obtained by the new york
times maps out the bite administration's
plans to significantly expand
the legal immigration system including
methodically reversing the efforts to
dismantle it
by the former president donald j trump
fox news contributor tom homan
is the former acting director of eyes
tom great to see you today thank you so
much for being with us
you know this is so curious to me so
they want to increase
legal immigration and yet at the same
time we're seeing enormous jumps we can
put the numbers up
for everybody at home in in illegal
immigration as it comes across the
border and we see those migrant
encounters
popping dramatically so what is that
where does that leave us
lisa's in a really bad spot look the
number of crossers at the board
especially especially children that come
across the border in the last few months
is the most we've ever seen in history
of the united states border show
illegal entries on the border is
unprecedented at the same time
immigration and customs enforcement your
interior immigration enforcement
had the lowest level levels of removals
so you had a record number of illegal
entries
lowest level removals and that's not by
accident as many times as by design
as far as anthony blinking going to
central america it's a waste of time
it's pure ignorance because all they got
to do is reverse what they're doing go
back to the trump policies
there are policies that are driving this
surge at the border
even the president of mexico said that
when you say you're going to open your
border up you're not going to detain
you're going to put a moratorium on
deportations you're going to reward
amnesty and daca
and at the same time offer free health
care that's what's causing this crisis
it's about his administration's policies
and that's clear
they seem to want to reverse a lot of
what you did during the trump years
uh and we've seen that over and again
but tom i if
if you just listen to joe biden talk
this should not really be a surprise
i mean there's there's video of him in
iowa in
august of 2019 and he made that comment
about you could easily absorb two
million more
immigrants or refugees in the united
states you could easily do that
so none of this really should be a
surprise
it shouldn't be a surprise because that
same month in august i wrote an op-ed
for fox news
and i specifically said if joe biden
becomes president
we lose the border we lose all the
success of president trump
you know gained on the border i don't
care if you like president trump or hate
president trump
everybody has your opinion but you
cannot argue the fact
that he gave us the most secure border
in my lifetime
in my career illegal immigration was
down 70 80
depending on what month you look at i
mean great success
so you look and as far as them wanting
to increase
illegal immigration let me be clear what
they're doing they're going to make
illegal immigration
legal they're going to do that two ways
mark my word first thing let's do is
they're going to change the asylum rules
because 90 percent of central americans
who claim asylum
never get relief from u.s courts because
they don't qualify so they're going to
change the rules and make it so they
qualify so if you're escaping domestic
violence
if you're escaping gang violence now
you're going to qualify which is exactly
which is is it doesn't say that the
statute you have to be escaping fear and
persecution from your home
government because of race religion or
political affiliation
they're going to change those rules and
they already made illegal immigration
legal in the united states as far as
isil concerned because if you're
illegally in the united states right now
and you walk up to an ice agent and say
i entered the country illegally last
year
a judge ordered me removed what are you
going to do about it
ice cannot arrest them because unless he
commits a serious aggravated family and
gets convicted of it
ice can't arrest anybody for being in
the united states illegally
anymore that's on the heels of the open
borders so that's what's driving this
crisis
even if you turn yourself into the
border patrol and you get into united
states
you get order removed no one's removing
you because they change
ice policy also you know we've heard the
opposite from the administration
jen saki has said from the podium that
the overwhelming majority of people who
try to cross are are being sent back
and yet everything that you're saying
indicates that that is
not the case and you're talking about
the agenda you know in many ways it
would
then in that case they should go to the
border and say this is working well you
know we wanted to have two million more
people come in
uh the numbers are where we expected
them to be
and this is part of our policy with
regard to ice this is from the new york
post today
president biden is putting ice on ice
agents say they now spend their time on
paperwork
working out or not working at all they
actually fear being disciplined
more than i'm sorry they fear being
disciplined
more from making an arrest than not
making an arrest and it goes on tom your
reaction
all right absolutely i thought you said
it's all the time first off john saki's
lying
the majority of family units are being
released in the united states the cbp
border patrol stats clearly say that
anybody go to the website look
100 children are being released the only
ones are returning are
uh uh uh adult uh singles males and
females
if they don't qualify for covet and
minute title 42
ends they're gonna come so and and
there's a thousand and fifteen hundred
got aways
a day these are the single adults who
don't qualify for being released united
states they're sneaking in
and again once they get arrested you
can't remove them because
isis policies ice is in a bad place the
the the morale ice is at all time low
because they can't arrest somebody from
being in the country illegally
border patrol morale as an all-time low
let me tell you a quick story i took a
flight from rio grande valley to dallas
to get my connecting flight back to dc i
met six border patrol agents who just
entered their detail were going home
after 90 days on the border next to them
were 14 family units
almost 40 illegal aliens with a plane
ticket purchased by the u.s taxpayer
to get them to their final destination
sitting next to the same
orbital agents that arrested them two
days earlier and you want to talk about
morale the border patrol
these men and women are putting their
lives online they're sitting on a plane
where someone and the government's gonna
get into their final destination
they all they gotta do is get to the
border u.s government getting the rest
of the way
under the ministry extraordinary thank
you tom kamala harris guatemalan mexico
a week from today two-day visit there
thank you tom for coming in today i'm
steve ducey i'm brian killman and i'm
ainsley erhardt and click here to
subscribe to the fox news youtube page
to catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis